everyone hello from san francisco uh bay
area where i'm at this morning at my
house it's super early it's dark outside
i don't know if you can tell from the
windows behind me but um thanks for
having me um
by the way i just want to mention as we
get into this this is the very first
like non-technical talk i've ever given
in my whole life
so
just a disclaimer um might be a little
rough but hopefully this is something
fun that teaches you a little bit about
personal finance so with that said let's
get right into it um a little bit about
my background
so i'm randall super nice to meet you
i'm the head of developer advocacy at a
company called octa we're like a web
security company that makes
authentication and authorization simpler
um
my background is i do a lot of python
javascript and go link development
i've been doing open source work for
about 20 years so i build and maintain
quite a few open source developer tools
i'm an author so i've published a couple
books
and i'm also a builder i run several api
services that are quite popular for
developers and i run lots of different
like command line tooling and have some
some consumer projects and stuff like
that that i work on in my free time and
i just generally
love programming things and so
it's it's been like a passion of my life
and
a while back so maybe about 12 years ago
now i also got really into personal
finance and it's just something that i
sort of geeked out on for a while and
i'm one of those people where when i get
into something i just love to
read books about it watch youtube videos
about it you know read forums listen to
podcasts and it's something that just
sort of stuck with me and so for the
last i want to say maybe
10 11 12 years something like that it's
just been a continued hobby of mine
and so uh before we start talking about
the main thing today i just wanted to
share my personal story um i've never
really talked about this with other
people by the way
but i just wanted to sort of set the
stage for what i'm going to be sharing
with you so
this is me um you know obviously i look
a lot worse than dexter from dexter's
lab does but this is sort of me
when i got started programming um when i
was really young
and when i got out of high school i went
to the university of california in the
state where i live and i started working
on a computer science degree
and when i was working on my computer
science degree while i did really well
in my computer science classes i was
basically terrible at like literally
everything else you know i had to take
general ed classes and history and art
and things like that and i just honestly
hated it and i did not force myself to
do the work and so as a result of that i
dropped out of school on my second year
after my second year school was done
and so when this happened
it was a terrible part of my life i was
like super depressed i had to move back
home with my parents and i basically had
around 75 000 or so of student loan debt
which is just a ton of money coming out
of school
and i was trying to figure out what i
was going to do with my life and how i
was going to turn things around
and what i did is i started just i
figured okay first thing i need to do is
like pay down some of this damn debt
because like i basically have these
crazy monthly payments i had to pay
something like 3 000 a month like
minimum just to keep things current and
it stressed me out like crazy
and so what i did was i applied a bunch
of jobs luckily the very first job i
applied to gave me an offer which was
amazing i accepted it like right away
and so i started working full time in
the tech industry
now i wasn't making a ton of money or
anything but i was living at home with
my parents and i saved everything i had
and used it to paint on my debt
and so around a year later when i left
this job
i by that point in time i paid off
around thirty thousand dollars on my
debt and so my total net worth was
around negative forty five thousand
dollars
and when i left this company i went to
work with a couple of people that i met
a couple friends and they had a product
that was already out that was already
successful and i started building and
maintaining the product and over the
next five years or so i helped launch
new business lines there we did a bunch
of brand new things and it was crazy fun
and i ended up getting paid a lot more
than i was making in my first job
and around this time i also got married
um my wife was working full time as well
and so we basically just tried to live
like relatively frugally we didn't
really think about it too much and we
just tried to pay down our debt and save
as much money as possible
so after doing that for a number of
years i ended up working with another
group of friends at another tech company
startup that went pretty well
and uh basically four years ago our
company got acquired by the company i
work at today which is called octa when
so for the last you know four years i've
just been working at octa running
developer advocacy building all sorts of
cool web security tools and things like
that so it's been it's been really fun
but the reason i'm bringing this story
up is because it wasn't really until
this part of my life after my first job
that i really started thinking about
what i want to do with my finances like
it wasn't until then that i thought
about should i even be saving money um
like how much should i save like am i
going to have any money in the future it
didn't really register to me before this
point in my life i was basically just
sort of going through the motions if i
had money i might just spend it on
whatever i didn't really think things
through
so
today um it's been quite a long journey
so i've been working in the industry
professionally for 12 years now
and
about two years ago my wife and i hit
what i would call financial independence
which basically means we have enough
money invested that we no longer need to
work and so when we hit that point we
both realized oh [ __ ] we could retire
right now if we wanted to we can keep
working we can change jobs we can do all
these different things and it was this
like incredibly freeing feeling
and it took us about 10 years from the
moment we started until we hit enough
money that we were we knew we'd be able
to retire safely
and so the way this works the the way
financial independence works at least in
the us and by the way
as we're as i'm giving this talk today
i'm going to
talk about like the concepts for
financial independence but the reality
is that like depending on the country
you're in and the locale there's
different rules and taxes and different
things you can do to optimize i'm very
familiar with them in particular in the
us in california so i'm going to be like
leaving a lot of those u.s specific
things out
but in general i think the rules are
very similar across different countries
but anyways the high level of it is that
the way financial independence works is
basically there's this thing called the
four percent rule it was a study that
was done where a bunch of researchers
analyzed the performance of the stock
market over a very long period of time
and said hey if you just have all of
your money invested in the stock market
over a long period of time how much of
that money can you live off of every
year without ever running out of money
and it turns out the answer is four
percent okay so what that means is that
if you have a hundred thousand dollars
invested in the stock market
then on average you'll be able to
withdraw four thousand of those dollars
per year to spend and live off of
and that's inflation adjusted by
adjusted by the way so over time that
4000 will increase a little bit as money
becomes less valuable
but the idea is that if you invest 100
000
then every year you can spend 4 000
without ever running out of money which
is pretty cool
that also means if you have a million
dollars invested you can spend 40 000 a
year without ever running out of money
which is pretty cool right same thing
2.5 million dollars means you have a
hundred thousand dollars a year to spend
and the quick math you can use to figure
this out is basically this the amount of
money you need to retire early or be
financially independent the freedom
number as i would like to call it
is however much money you spend every
year times 25
so it's really a simple formula and this
will basically let you back your way
into this four percent calculation
so here's some more quick math you can
look at if you just want to get inspired
um if you know that you need to spend 75
000 a year then congratulations that
means you need to save up 1 million 875
000 worth of investments to be
financially independent to go retire and
you know be on the beach somewhere
whatever you want to do right and so
very simple formula
so with that being said my plan for
today is to really talk you through how
to get here um i'm going to share what
i've learned from my journey and then
also what i've learned from lots of the
other people that have helped me figure
this stuff out so this is a combination
of sources um at the end of this talk i
have a bunch of links to resources that
i found really useful when i was
learning this stuff hopefully it'll be
useful to you as well and yeah we'll
just sort of have some fun with it
but before i do that there's one thing i
want to mention
i just wanted to acknowledge some stuff
that is slightly uncomfortable
so the first thing is that look
i realized talking about finance in the
middle of a global pandemic is somewhat
insensitive
and here's the thing right like all of
us all of you watching this are
incredibly privileged you know like
we're online
watching a cool conference with a bunch
of extremely brilliant technical minds
all around the world and we're just
lucky right as engineers all of us earn
far more money than like average
employees throughout the world
our profession's in really high demand
and generally our profession is one of
the the better pandemic proof ones and
so i just want to acknowledge that like
we're all in an extremely fortunate
position to even be thinking about this
stuff and so i just didn't want to let
that go to waste
but with that said let's continue on
so
i've laid this out in terms of five core
steps that you can take to really get
you to like be being financially
independent um the first step is to
understand where you're at today and
this is critical no matter what your
goal is whether it's finance stuff
health stuff relationship stuff
no matter what it is right like you have
to understand where you're at today if
you're going to change where you're at
in the future
and in particular there's four things
that are really really good to track if
you're not tracking them already okay
the first thing is your burn rate like
how much money are you spending every
single month you can also call us like
your budget you know your your spending
whatever it is just track this
the second thing is debt how much money
do you owe to other people
also you need to track your assets so
how much how many positive value things
do you have do you want a house is that
house worth a hundred thousand dollars
well that's an asset do you own a car
that's worth ten thousand dollars that's
also an asset do you have a hundred
thousand dollars of investments in the
bank that's also an asset right
and then finally your net worth is
really valuable to track especially in
the long run because it helps you see
like this long trend line
but basically your net worth what you do
is you take all your assets and you
subtract all your debts and that gives
you a number which says here's how much
you're worth and the idea is that over
time you want to see that number go up
and to the right at least hopefully
right you don't want to see it go down
and to the right that would be bad you
want to go up over time
now out of all these things you're
tracking the most important by far is
how much money you spend your budget
basically and the reason this is so
important is because if you look at
these other things here if you look at
your net worth your debt your assets all
of these things are not really that easy
to control right like if you've already
got a hundred thousand dollars of
student loan debt you can't really
control that too much now yeah you could
take out more debt and just do make
terrible choices obviously
but you don't want to do that but what
i'm saying is it's not that easy to
improve all these things except for your
your spending you can directly control
your spending and so it's one of the
most important things you need to be on
top of
now in the us there's a couple automated
tracking tools i use which i'm
absolutely in love with
i use the tool called mint.com which is
great for budgeting this is actually an
example a screenshot of part of my
budget from a couple months ago
you can see that for example my wife and
i spent 937 dollars this month on food
like groceries and restaurants
we spent 33 dollars shopping on amazon
now this this was a particularly low
month it wasn't exactly the best
representation but you get the idea mint
will do things like connect to your bank
account and credit cards and pull in all
the spending that you make and let you
categorize it's pretty cool
um the other thing i like using is
personal capital in the us personal
capital lets you track your investments
and basically lets you see how is your
money allocated
there's a couple like issues with the
software but generally it's pretty
helpful
i'm sure these things exist for those of
you that live outside the us as well
it's just a matter of sort of finding a
tracking tool that you like and sticking
with it
all right so that's the first thing step
two
is making a budget and sticking to it
and as my mom would sort of say you just
have to make sure you know where your
money is going this is really important
right
and the way you should run a monthly
budget because i've talked to tons of
people about this and i realize almost
no one has any idea how to do it
the the ideal way in my opinion to run a
monthly budget is like this first of all
you want to track all of your spending
by category you don't just want to say
i'm going to spend 5 000 this month what
you want to say is i'm going to spend
100 on you know my phone i'm going to
spend 200 on utilities whatever it is
you want to be specific that will make
you it far easier for you to hold
yourself accountable
secondly you want to assign realistic
budgets for each category
so a common mistake people make
including me i screwed this up it took
me six months before i got it right a
common mistake people make is they work
on a budget and when they start doing it
they're like i'm gonna save so much
money i'm only gonna spend 200 this
month on food and it's not gonna work so
just be realistic or as realistic as
possible
uh number three
you wanna make sure that you're tracking
this damn thing like all the time at
least once a week you should be like
looking at your budget how much you
spent how much you have left if you
don't look at it it's literally useless
because it will not have enough you know
space in your mind to like be impactful
and the fourth thing is if you have a
partner a spouse a husband a wife
whatever whatever situation you're in
you want to discuss and plan a budget
with your partner every single month
um budgeting isn't something you just do
like once and then forget about it's
something you need to do literally every
month and so what i do is once a month i
talk with my wife and we figure out
what do we want to spend money on next
month
like it's fine if we change the budget
you know like if we decide we want to go
on a vacation spend 2 000
that's fine we just put it in the budget
that's the important part
and the other thing i would just say is
when you break your
your budget up into categories
use real categories like use things that
make sense so if you have a lot of debt
have a category for debt so you know how
much you're spending on that if you have
transportation costs put that in there
if you're giving gifts to people put
gifts in there
really go in depth and make it something
that is going to be useful to you
now warning this is something that
should be pretty obvious but i've
noticed a lot of people that like
literally do not do this
but when you're planning your budget for
the following month if you notice that
your expenses are going to be more than
the money you make from your work or
your investments or whatever it is
then you need to cut your expenses
now that sounds like sort of obvious
right like don't spend more money than
you make but trust me i know tons of
people that make fantastic amounts of
money that like do not do this and it's
a core concept in eventually getting to
a point where you could retire early or
just like work on things you like so
make sure you always always stick to
this rule
now why is it so important to budget the
main reason it's so important to budget
is because you don't want to be like
this guy now i've been working in the
tech industry in california for 12 years
now professionally and
i've met a lot of just absolutely
amazing rock star programmers that are
like world famous people and one of the
things i've noticed is that even though
you can be this like brilliant person
and be a great engineer and be like
incredibly smart um it doesn't exempt
you from looking back over the last
couple years of your life and realizing
that you know maybe you've been pouring
your heart and soul into your work and
you've been doing all this great stuff
and you've been killing it but you don't
really have anything to show for it at
the end of the day and so it's really
easy no matter how much money you make
to just not think about it and just sort
of like blow money here and there and
just really wake up a couple years later
and realize damn i put in all this work
for years and i just don't really have
that much to show for it and so
budgeting is the thing that will prevent
this from being you so make sure you do
that
all right the third step is you really
want to pay off all of your debts as
soon as possible
and uh there's a lot of reasons for this
um part of it's also like a theoretical
exercise but i'll sort of walk you
through some of the reasoning
now before we go into the reasoning side
there's two types of debt you should
know about
the first type of debt is what we call
consumer debt and consumer debt are
credit cards you have payment plans so
if you purchase an iphone but you don't
pay the full price you just pay like 20
a month or whatever that is a form of
debt you're on a payment plan um car
loans personal loans anything like that
these are all things that you purchased
that are consumption related
on the other hand you have non-consumer
debts and these are things that while
they can sort of be argued our
consumption um a lot of the times
they're not so for example medical debt
in the u.s that's something that's a
very real concern people have
home loans so if you purchase a home and
you don't have the money just buy it
outright obviously you're going to be
taking on some some housing expenses
there
student loans these are all things that
are very very common
but
generally considered to be not consumer
focused debt
now these two types of debt are
different so consumer debt for example
is without question worse than
non-consumer debt consumer debt is
always going to have a higher interest
rate so it's going to cost you more
money to have consumer debt um
non-consumer debt can sometimes be
potentially a good thing like if you
purchase a house on a loan
there's a lot of ways that like that
could potentially be a good investment
and so
you don't have to necessarily pay off
like your house loan but it is something
that i would personally recommend
now
when you're going through paying off
debt if you have debt there's a couple
different ways you can go about it
um the first way is is a pattern called
the snowball method and this is
basically where you decide to pay off
your smallest debt first and then your
next smallest debt and then your next
smallest debt until eventually you get
to the largest debt and what you do is
you basically just throw whatever extra
money you have left at the end of every
month into this debt to get rid of it
quickly
um if you take a look at a real world
example of this here's here's a pretty a
good approximation
so let's say
as an example that
you have 52 000 total worth of debt you
have a thousand dollar credit card a
four thousand dollar credit card a seven
thousand dollar personal loan some
student loans and here's how much you
pay every month and here's the interest
rates on the loans
now i've organized these from smallest
to largest but i've organized them so
the consumer debt is first because again
consumer debt should always take
precedence if you're going to pay things
off over non-consumer debt
now
imagine that
you know you're working you're paying
for all of your living expenses and
after all of your expenses you only have
75 a month left at the end of every you
know month
well what i would do if i was doing a
debt snowball to pay this stuff down
is i would start putting my extra 75 a
month into this the smallest debt first
this 1 000 credit card bill and once
this is paid off now i'm going to have
75 a month left over every month plus
the 94 a month that i was previously
spending on this this credit card
payment and so my total extra income at
the end of every month would be 169
then i would just do it again for this
loan and when this was paid off my
income that's left over at the end of
every paycheck is going to jump up by
380
and so forth and so on until eventually
i when i paid all these things off i
have an extra 1329 left at the end of
the month and as you can see i mean
you know a lot of people don't really
think about how much debt they have but
if you add up all the payments and you
sort of look through it it can be
astounding how much money you actually
earn by like just not having to pay
other people so i highly recommend you
track your debt you try to get rid of it
as fast as possible
because it opens up a lot of other
options once you hit this point
[Music]
now the next option you have is to pay
down your debts by
the most efficient way possible which is
really like targeting the highest
interest loans first and this works the
exact same way as the debt snowball
method except instead of organizing from
smallest to largest you're organizing
from largest interest to smallest
interest
so for example if you have two loans a
35 dollar car loan that's charging you
twelve percent interest
or a five thousand dollar personal loan
that's charging you seven percent
interest
you would pay down the twelve percent
interest loan first
and if you think about this it's the
most efficient way to do it because
let's say you have a hundred dollars
extra that you want to pay down on one
of these loans at the end of the month
if you put a hundred dollars into the
personal loan
at seven percent interest then you're
basically saving yourself seven cents on
the dollar in the future right because
that's how much interest they're
charging you if you put it into
the 35 000 loan then you're saving
yourself 12 cents on the dollar so you
have a net positive gain of 5 cents
because that's per dollar because that's
the difference between these two loan
percentages and so
this is the most efficient way
mathematically to pay off debt
now which of these two methods should
you decide to follow well if you're like
me and you want a lot of flexibility and
options and you're sort of risk averse i
would go for the debt snowball method
because it gives you a lot more momentum
it feels good to have extra money in
your budget at the end of the month as
you pay stuff off quickly but if you
just want to maximize how much money you
have and how much money you're making
then go for the interest-based loan
repayment um it's definitely the the
more effective way to do it if you
really care about the dollars and cents
and why is it important to pay off debt
so this is just my personal opinion but
a lot of people
have no problem hanging on to debt um
i'm not really one of them i am a huge
huge proponent of getting rid of
whatever debt you have and the reason
why is because it gives you a ton of
flexibility and options and the main
reason is it just reduces stress i still
remember very clearly what it felt like
when i dropped out of college and had
this huge amount of student loans and
you know having to pay thousands of
dollars a month when you are literally
broke and have nothing
i just viscerally remember that feeling
and it was so stressful and so you know
just gave me so much anxiety that as i
paid things off it like dramatically
improved my life and my mindset and my
health and everything i just felt better
like you feel unburdened not having to
worry about paying other people for
living you know
all right so the next step step four
step four is all about saving your money
now i know you all hopefully know this
is gonna be in here
but yeah it's just really about saving
money uh something parents will tell you
all the time right like don't forget to
save your money
so the question is how much money should
you save
and the answer in my opinion is you
should have six months of your living
expenses saved up this is pretty general
advice from like most financial advisors
will tell you something similar
um but basically it's having an
emergency fund that's around six months
worth of living expenses
now this money should be used for things
like emergency car repairs if you have a
leaky roof on your house a family
emergency a job loss and having six
months worth of living expenses
in savings is like honestly one of the
best investments you can make it just
reduces your stress almost to nothing
and i'm telling you this from personal
experience once you have a comfortable
buffer there it means that if you lose
your job you just don't care because you
can live for six months you can
literally not earn a cent and you'll be
and you'll be completely fine you can
just find a new job um it means you can
if you have a major problem like a
health issue or your car stops working
it doesn't cause you any stress because
you have this money sitting in an
account you can use to cover these
expenses and so it's just a really
really nice way to like live and it will
make you feel far better
and i think that you know in the middle
of a global pandemic that we are now in
it really highlights the need for having
something like this i mean how many
people have were seriously impacted by
covid and lost their jobs lost their
source to income for a while so having
at least six months of
living expenses saved up is just very
free
um here's a real a real world example by
the way i'm going to use this later in
the talk as well but
what i'm doing here is i'm going to show
you how to sort of budget and stuff and
how to and how like to save an emergency
fund from the perspective of a brand new
junior developer who just graduated
university who lives in california who
got their first programming job
so if you live in california and you got
a programming job it's very common for
new developers to make around a hundred
thousand dollars in salary okay
now if you live in california that means
you're going to be taxed approximately
30
of that money which means that after all
of your expenses your paycheck every
month will be around 5
900 a month which is you know very good
um
i also projected that a junior developer
living in california can probably fairly
easily live on twenty seven hundred
dollars a month
which means they would have three
thousand two hundred dollars a month
left over to save now let me walk you
through this mock budget that i put
together i basically said that out of
this 2 700 a month a person might spend
100 a month on entertainment you know
movies netflix whatever
1450 a month on rent
750 a month on food
50 a month on transportation 50 a month
on personal care 200 a month for
utilities and 100 a month for gifts now
this is a a realistic but not
extravagant budget so this is absolutely
doable for a programmer that lives in
california that isn't you know isn't
anything special basically
now in this case
this person should have a six-month
emergency fund and what that means is
you take the amount of money they spend
every month so twenty seven hundred
dollars you multiply it by six and that
gives you sixteen thousand two hundred
dollars to work with all right that
should be how much you save up
um at this rate if you're only spending
twenty seven hundred dollars a month and
you're saving three thousand two hundred
dollars a month that means it can take
you a little more than five months to
save up an emergency fund and so that's
pretty damn crazy right like that's
that's not bad
it will only take you six months let's
say to save up a six month emergency
fund that's absolutely fantastic but the
only reason you're able to do that again
is because you're making a good salary
you're making a decent amount of money
here and so it's easier to save a higher
percentage of it
now when you do this uh where should you
keep your money the answer is just a
normal savings account at your bank um
you know that's what i do um i'm not
sure how it works overseas but in the us
at least the money you put in the sami's
account is backed by the federal
government so even if your bank goes out
of business like there's no risk that
you're going to run out of money or
anything like that um all your money is
safe and protected
all right
so step five
investing your money this is the final
step in becoming financially independent
that you have to understand
now the reason investing is so important
is because there's only two things that
you can invest in and by the way i see
the chat talking about how this example
is unrealistic i will happily talk about
that afterwards but this is a very
realistic budget that i've personally
lived on
i actually spend less than this today so
i'm more than happy to talk about that
later if you want
but uh
going back to the investing part one of
the reasons investing so important is
because there's only a couple things you
can do with your money the first thing
is you can save it right now savings
fantastic because you can't lose the
money that you're saving put in a
savings account right it's just gonna
sit there but the downside to saving is
that interest rates are low which means
banks aren't going to pay you
basically anything
for keeping your money with them so
you're not going to earn any money
the second thing is that if you think
about it the money you put into savings
is really
losing value because inflation goes up
every year in the us the inflation rate
is approximately two to three percent
every year but on a savings account like
my savings account today pays me point
six percent interest so if inflation
goes up two percent this year and my
bank pays me point six percent interest
on my money there's a one point four
percent value of the money i've saved
that has been lost so i'm actually
losing more money than i'm saving does
that make sense
so saving isn't a good long-term
strategy it's literally only used as
some a form of insurance like an
emergency fund basically
so your other choice is to invest and
this is what you have to do now
investing is going to earn you on
average much higher returns than saving
in the long run you know in the us the
historical 90-year average of the stock
market is around 9.8
before you factor in inflation that is
way more than the 0.6 percent you can
earn on a bank account
this higher return is going to protect
your money from being eaten away by
inflation
and
the the final thing is that investing is
also just really risky okay so
unlike a savings account where you put
your money in there it's totally safe
and secure when you're investing money
in buying companies like publicly traded
companies it's a risky proposition your
money might go down it might go up it's
very volatile but in the long run it
tends to perform really well
so
let's take a look at the same junior
developer who's making a hundred
thousand dollars in california who's
living off twenty seven hundred dollars
a month
this person's retirement goal from the
day they start working would basically
be eight hundred and ten thousand
dollars now the way i figured that out
was i took their amount of money they
spend every month i multiplied it by 12
to get their annual expenditure then i
multiplied that by 25 and so this backs
us into that four percent rule that we
saw earlier
now
how long do you think it would take
for this junior developer to save up
enough money and invest enough money to
retire based on these stats so they're
earning a hundred thousand dollars
they're saving 3200 a month and
investing it and they basically need to
hit 810 000 minimum to be able to to be
able to retire early be financially
independent whatever you want to call it
well if you do the math on this it will
take this person approximately 12 years
of working assuming they get no raises
and their budget stays exactly the same
as we just talked about and this is
based on again the historical returns
from the u.s stock market
but that's crazy right like if you
get out of high school at age 18 you get
a four-year university degree so you're
22 and you work for 12 years so you're
34 years old you could have enough money
to retire by the time you're 34 years
old which is pretty insane um and that's
something that is a really lucky uh
thing that just a lot of engineers can
literally do this you know um
of course you're gonna get raises you're
gonna move up you're gonna earn more
money in your career stuff like that so
it makes this all the more possible
now if you don't want to invest let's
just say you just want to save your
money i've talked to some people where
they're like i hate investing i'm super
against it i just want to save and pile
up my money how long would it take you
to hit that 810 000 goal it would
actually take you 20 years so it would
take you eight additional years of your
life to be able to save up to hit this
eight hundred thousand dollar-ish amount
now the other problem of course is that
whole four percent rule for financial
independence we talked about earlier is
based on you having your money invested
like invested not in a savings account
and the reason why is because investment
returns are much higher than the
interest you earn on a savings account
and so
if you are you know just saving money
you're never really going to be able to
retire unless you have way way way more
than 25 times your annual expenses
[Music]
all right so now let's talk
quickly talk about how the stock market
works so the stock market is just a
bunch of companies that you can buy a
portion of
and stocks are sold through an exchange
in the u.s we have a few different
exchanges one of them is called the new
york stock exchange london they have the
london stock exchange it's very
different
um if you as a as an individual want to
buy stock the way you do it is you sign
up with a brokerage account on the us we
have ones like vanguard e-trade fidelity
they're all totally fine i actually use
vanguard personally and you can
basically give money to vanguard and say
vanguard i would like to buy some stock
please and they will talk to the new
york stock exchange and make that happen
now here's the thing though if you're
investing by just buying lots of shares
to google or facebook or amazon or
whatever it's extremely risky right
because what happens if google goes
bankrupt or amazon you know you know uh
i don't know alibaba decides to just
destroy amazon in the us or something
right like there's a million things that
can go wrong with a single company so
it's really risky and it's not what you
want to do
so the way you should generally invest
your money is in this thing called index
funds and index funds are basically a
way to purchase
a lot of companies all at once so that
you reduce your risk
vanguard for example has indexed funds
that look like this
they have tons of them by the way but
these are some of the ones that are like
very very popular and well known so
the first one is called vtwax and
basically what this is if you purchase a
share if you purchase money into this
index fund you're basically buying a
little sliver of every company around
the world and what that means is that if
the entire world economy does well
your you will do well you the value of
the money you invested will go up and
over time that's historically what has
happened so like technology gets better
people become more wealthy like third
world countries start to develop more
infrastructure and become you know in a
better place and so generally things get
better in the long run um if you were to
put you can also purchase like just
parts of u.s companies which is a very
popular fund called vtsax for that so
you're basically investing in the us
economy you can purchase just shares of
non-us companies so international
companies um for me personally like my
wife and i have 70 of our money invested
in the u.s stock market and 30 invested
in the international markets and so
we're basically betting 70 of our money
that the u.s economy is going to do well
and 30 that the rest of the world is
going to do well and this is a very
common way to sort of break up your
investments
if you want to keep it really simple you
can literally just buy a single world
index fund like this one at the top here
and just be done with it and never think
about it again so it really could be
that easy
so just to recap here is the
step-by-step plan you need to basically
be able to retire early hit financial
independence have
control of your finances track your
spending and net worth
build and stick to a budget every single
month
pay off your debts
save a six-month emergency fund and
invest all of the extra money you have
into broadly diversified index funds if
you do this consistently over a long
period of time you're absolutely to hit
financial independence
it really is that simple
so now
we only have a few minutes left i know
i'm going to just run you through some
really fun stuff to talk about and think
about okay
these are also like a little bit of tips
for me
so the first thing i'm going to say
is that your savings rate is really
really important all right
so
it turns out that it doesn't necessarily
matter how much you make like yeah as an
engineer you're going to be making a lot
of money um just generally speaking of
course and that means you can save more
of it if you live a reasonable lifestyle
but it turns out that this is a pretty
easy formula to calculate so if you save
20
of your money then it would take you 37
years to have enough investments to
retire
if you save 50 percent of your money
half of whatever you make it'll take you
17 years to be able to retire
now let's just say that from the day the
first day you become an engineer you're
very smart with money and you save half
of everything and you start working at
age 22 that means that by age 39 you'd
have enough money to retire on which is
still an incredibly early retirement and
gives you a ton of freedom for your
entire life it's absolutely insane
but the really crazy thing
is what happens if you save more than
half of your money like what happens if
you save 75
of every dollar that you make um you
could literally retire in seven years
which is absolutely bananas my wife and
i were somewhere between 60 and 75
percent it took us about 10 years to hit
this mark
just as a reference point
but again we lived relatively frugal
lives we started learning about this
stuff fairly early on and we tried to
just be um very reasonable with the
things that we did
so here's some real world examples of
this
if you make 70 000 a year and you live
on half it'll take you 17 years to
retire
if you
make 120 000 a year and you live on 48
it will take you 12 and a half years to
retire
if you make 200 000 a year then live on
fifty thousand dollars
it will only take you seven years to you
know retire
and the important thing here that i
would encourage you to think about is it
doesn't matter how much you're making
today think about the future
so if you
literally live paycheck to paycheck
today that might be okay maybe you focus
on paying down your debts and that frees
up some extra money to invest maybe when
you get raises in the future or switch
jobs and like become more senior in your
career
you don't increase your lifestyle
expenses a lot and you just invest the
extra money there there's lots of ways
even if you're late in the game to make
up for this and to like catch up so
do not stress about these things i'm
just saying that these are supposed to
be motivational like seeing the numbers
at least for me was very inspiring early
on
so
the other thing i recommend is you know
you sort of treat this like a game a
little bit i love video games i don't
know about you all but i find them
really fun
one of the games i sort of played is i
built a spreadsheet and i sort of listed
off all the things i spend money on
every single month so i have like a
phone bill that's a hundred dollars a
month we spend around 100 a month on
entertainment 500 a month on groceries i
listed all these things out then what i
did is i calculated how much money i
would need invested to pay for this
particular bill like every single month
so for example
to cover my phone bill of 100 a month
and automatically in the future i would
need to invest thirty thousand dollars
and that's because if i multiply what
this works out to it's twelve hundred
dollars a year for my phone and if i
multiply that by twenty five it's thirty
thousand dollars so i knew when i hit my
first 30 000 of money invested that
guess what my phone bill is paid from
now into the future forever and it was
pretty cool and i just went through the
list and i wrote everything down and i
saved up and i had goals for each of
these items and as i saved up enough
money and invested enough money to cover
each of these bills i crossed them off
the list and i said look look at how
close we're getting to being financially
independent and it was just really
motivating and sort of fun
um
the next tip i have or the last tip i
have i think is to automate everything
now i'm a developer and i legitimately
spend i don't know at least 20 of my
time thinking about ways to automate my
work um i highly recommend you do the
same thing with your personal finances
so if you have debt you're paying down
automate that [ __ ] you know like set it
up so that whatever extra money you have
left over in your budget every month
gets automatically put into your
payments
um set up automatic savings have a
certain percent of the money when you're
saving up that emergency fund that gets
transferred from your checking account
into your savings account automatically
budgeting automate that use a tool like
mint.com or whatever you have available
in your in your country to make this
easier on you so you're not like looking
through credit card statements and bank
statements all this time
and then also investing so automate your
investing just like you would do a
savings set it all up so it's it's
super easy to handle
and this is something literally anyone
can do it just takes some focus and some
dedication but like you can absolutely
do this so don't feel like this is
something that's out of reach and also i
would say that we talked about some of
the extremes in here you know like yeah
it is possible to retire in 10 years if
you're extremely frugal but
this isn't a a rush right like you don't
have to have enough become financially
independent in 10 years or five years or
whatever crazy stuff other people are
doing you can take your time you know if
you just save 20 of your money you're
still going to retire early you're going
to be retired at 59 instead of 65. if
you save a little bit more than that
you're going to retire years earlier and
so
there's basically what i'm saying is
there's never a problem with saving more
and investing more it's only going to
help you and give you more options
so what did i skip in this presentation
well
because this is a 45 minute presentation
i had to skip some stuff so first of all
i skipped a lot of the very specific
things you should do to minimize taxes
in the us because this is not a
primarily us audience
i also skipped talking about alternative
investments which are things like
purchasing real estate handling
purchasing bonds cryptocurrencies all
that stuff um and the reason why is
because the four percent rule which
basically everyone uses is based on
investing in broadly diversified index
funds it's not based on these other
things and so i'm more than happy to
talk about that separately i actually do
own some real estate stuff we could get
into that but it just didn't really fit
in the context of the talk
we also didn't discuss the in-depth
debate around like whether you should
pay down your debt or invest
or taxes and tax planning and again some
of these things are personal decisions
people have to make and some are country
specific things and so it just wouldn't
really be appropriate
but the final thing i want to talk about
before we go is why why should you do
literally any of these things and i'm
going to give you my personal opinion on
this
a lot of people think that doing this is
a way to just live on the beach and like
be happy
and
um other people think it's a way to just
be able to buy more things and the
latest technology all the time and just
sort of you know
have a more glamorous lifestyle let's
say but i think there's two things that
are a lot more important than this the
first thing is that
if you are wise with your money it means
you can help more people like you can
dramatically impact more people's lives
maybe it means you can help a family
member who's struggling maybe it means
you can donate money to a cause you
really believe in
maybe it means you can like literally
just give extra tips to waiters and
waitresses when you see them at a
restaurant to help other people out but
it gives you the possibility to be
really generous and that's something
that i think is invaluable
and the final reason is that
it gives you control over your life you
know a lot of people are very caught up
in the day to day and they think about
hey i have to work at this job because i
need this paycheck and it doesn't
uh having that sort of scarcity mindset
right and not knowing if everything's
going to be okay takes a mental toll on
you and limits some of your ambition
and when you no longer have to worry
about where your next paycheck is coming
from it gives you the options to focus
on what i want to do with my life you
know like what sort of legacy do i want
to leave what do i want to be known for
do i want to uh be programming things
that help people do i want to work in
this industry or that industry it just
gives you a way to like connect and
just
live your best life i think and so this
is the real reason why you should at
least try to do some of these things
so with that i just want to say thank
you for your time it was super cool
being able to talk to all of you i will
be answering questions in the chat room
afterwards i know we're out of time um
you can always follow me on twitter and
hit me up as well you can also go to my
personal website i've written a couple
things about finance on there it's
mostly just technical stuff though
and then i also have a bunch of
recommended reading in these slides if
you go to my personal site these will be
posted up there later today and so
you'll be able